[Applause]
hello I'm mark Chen I'm a fellow in
CFR's gravity in the extreme universe
program and tonight I'm gonna tell you
about how we are exploring the dark
universe from 2 kilometers underground
so let me start with the composition of
the universe on this first slide so
since the dawn of civilization mankind
has sought to understand what are the
fundamental constituents of the world
around us what are the elements fire air
water earth from antiquity the Greeks
introduced the concept of the atom
chemistry brings us the periodic table
of the elements particle physicists
develop a standard model of the
elementary particles and cosmology and
astrophysicists
have observed the properties of the
galaxies and in the cosmos as well as
the Cosmic Microwave Background the
imprint of the radiation from the Big
Bang looking at the universe's earliest
baby pictures in order to understand
that this is the composition of the
universe but the universe is made up of
something called dark energy which I
won't be able to describe tonight and
that's the dominant composition
component of the universe there's
something called dark matter which I'll
try to describe for you and the ordinary
matter that that particles that we
understand the makeup the stage that
make up the telus Park Center that make
up you and I the that's only 5% of the
universe and so what is this dark matter
we have evidence for a dark matter from
this image but from also from many
observations in in astrophysics this
image is actually a composite of three
different images there are galaxies and
that are in the background and image and
overlaid in red are is an image in the
x-ray showing hot gas that resulted when
two galaxy clusters
billions of years ago have that a pass
through each other and the resulting
interaction of the hot gas of the gas
gave rise to that signature that's
observed but what's also shown is the
gravitational image in blue and that
gravitational image is produced by some
matter and we see that that matter is
what's responsible for clumping ordinary
matter like that make up the the
galaxies that are observed and that this
this blue material this matter has
actually passed through each other
without interacting so this is that
image tells us something about what dark
matter is what physicists have have
figured out in terms of dark matter is
that we know that dark matter is
nonbaryonic that means it's made up of
particles that are not like ordinary
matter that are like the protons and
neutrons and electrons that you might be
familiar with physicists know that the
dark matter is very weakly interacting
because it appears to be collisionless
so that its interactions are purely
gravitational as far as the observations
that we can make that dark matter is
cold it's made up of nonrelativistic
particles that it clumps together
because of gravity and as a result the
Dark Matter provides the seed that
allows galaxies clusters of galaxies the
large-scale structure of the universe to
exist as we observe it and as our
simulations can can predict and and and
be compared with observation look what
physicists don't know is exactly what
kind of particles form the dark matter
that pervades the universe and there are
several ideas and in the leading ideas
include something called supersymmetry
that produces a wimp a weakly
interacting massive particle extra
space-time dimensions the excitations
could be a particle of could be could
manifest itself as a particle dark
matter something called accion's and so
the question is how do we detect dark
matter how do we determine what it is
and on this slide it's a simplified
overview of the ideas
that particle theorists have about dark
matter and it shows that it there's many
many ideas and I'll point out actually
this slide comes from 2013 and seven
years ago in the seven years we haven't
simplified this any further
so stole our picture in from theory is
like this but we need to go after this
to understand the nature of dark matter
with experiment and see what what that
tells us so one of the types of
experiments that is pursuing the
detection of dark matter is to build
very large detectors deep underground so
we seek shelter underground from cosmic
radiation so we're constantly bombarded
by radiation from space high-energy
particles that rained down on us and so
we go deep underground and so that these
particles will be screened by the
material above and so we when we locate
are very sensitive detectives below
we're hoping that these very weakly
interacting particles will pass through
and that we can observe them that way
and so in Canada we have one of the
world leading facilities for this type
of physics experiment and what we have
is in the one of the mines one of the
very deep mines in Sudbury we have a
underground lab that's called snow lab
and and what we've done really over the
past 20 years is we've carved out of
rock and produced a very quiet location
which we can place the most sensitive
detectors to search for dark matter and
so snow lab is follow-on to the Sudbury
neutrino Observatory the results from
that original project garnered the Nobel
Prize for our MacDonald in 2015 and so
we're continuing with snow lab with new
experiments I'll just show you a few of
the pictures of what we're doing and
then afterwards if you're curious about
what these detectors are then please
come and talk to me so here is an
illustration here are photos no no no
this reason the photos of the the new
neutrino detector as it's been refurbish
and you can see that here my colleague
is putting the finishing touches on the
upgraded neutrino detector that's
currently taking data now
this is detective that's filled with
3,000 kilograms of liquid argon so
liquid argon is is an minus 190 degrees
Celsius its argon as a gas that's a
abundant in ordinary air and when you
cool it down to those temperatures when
you liquefy it it becomes a detector
that then produces flashes of light that
can be very distinct distinctive between
interactions of dark matter and ordinary
matter and here this detector is cooled
to below one degree above absolute zero
and when dark matter particles will
strike this detector it'll produce a
pulse of heat heat up these detectors a
small degree and they can be measured
very very sensitive detectors and we're
also hoping with this installation being
installed in snow lab in the next few
years that will people try to detect
dark matter that way and so the quest to
understand the nature and composition of
the universe continues and I think
there's light at the end of the tunnel
thanks very much
[Applause]